hi everyone so we're getting we're gonna
get started now I want to welcome to
welcome you to our conversation today
which is jointly sponsored by AE 380
which is a legendary Stanford class
that's been around I'm told for a half a
century a roughly a half century and the
Asilomar microprocessor workshop which
is now virtually sadly in its 46th year
my name is John Markoff I'm a fellow at
the Stanford Institute for human
centered artificial intelligence and
before we go any farther I want to say
thank you to Dennis Allison Dennis gets
credit for organizing doing much of the
organizing work of this event and I just
wanted to say that I've known Dennis
since the late 70s of the early 1980s
and when I was a cub reporter dennis was
the source to die from Dennis was
someone who knew everyone in Silicon
Valley so you just had to ask Dennis who
you should talk to him Dennis would tell
you there was an interesting situation
early on when I was at byte magazine
where there were two startup companies
one was called forefront and one was
called the other was called free thought
and I should have put the wrong company
and Dennis was on the board of both
companies and so I know he was on the
Houston adviser to both companies
because his students were both companies
he showed up at the wrong company and
took me to the right company so very
well-connected guy today I think you
you'll see them if you could put the
speakers on the screen you'll see the
speakers names and your screen I'm going
to ask the panelists to briefly
introduce themselves rather than taking
a lot of time to introduce people so
that we can get right into it
our topic is coming attractions and
Dennis is called it death or utopia in
the next three decades and I assume that
if we weren't in the middle of a global
pandemic this would have been dystopian
utopia but he's being very blunt and I
by way of introduction I just wanted to
say that the way we envision the future
is not irrelevant and I can give you a
couple
very specific examples of why that I
believe that's true and why how we view
the future actually is significant in
shaping the future when I started work
on a recent book I discovered that
several actually many well-known
artificial intelligence scientists had
come into the field because of something
they read in usually science fiction or
saw for example rod Brooks and Jerry
Kaplan who were two early pioneers in
the field of robotics and artificial
intelligence went into the field after
they watched the movie 2001 Space
Odyssey they both decided they wanted to
build half and that's not the reaction I
would have had but go figure
furthermore atom Shire and Tom Gruber
who were the two technical architects of
Siri Apple's a speech interface both Rai
scientists both decided they wanted to
build Siri after they saw an Apple
public relations video produced by John
Sculley in the late 1980s called
knowledge navigator and that led them
directly to Siri so our conversation you
know so if this is a consensual
hallucination we should pay attention to
it is my argument so our conversation is
going to be wide open today
you can touch on economy culture
politics biology technology but I wanted
to start with the winds as wide open as
we can make it and I wanted to start
with climate and so I wanted to you know
we're really lucky we have Michael Mann
who's a well-known climate scientist
with us today and I wanted to start by
asking Michael if you could frame the
consensus in the climate community about
climate over the next three decades to
sort of give us the the broadest you
know pouring field we can to get started
on yeah thanks John it's great to be
part of this conversation well it's
interesting because there were a couple
of time horizons that were actually
spelled out in the description of this
this event 2030 and 2050 and those
happened to be very interesting sort of
timeframes when it comes to the issue of
tackling the climate crisis because as
we have you know widely heard now 2030
within the next 10 years we've got to
bring our carbon emissions down by a
factor of 2 and we've got to bring them
to net zero net zero emissions that
means no more carbon going into the
atmosphere than is coming out of the
atmosphere by 2050 by mid-century if we
are to avert warming the planet by more
than about a degree and a half Celsius
roughly three degrees a little less than
three degrees Fahrenheit which is sort
of a threshold of warming where we start
to see the worst impacts of climate
change but let's be frank here we are
already seeing dangerous climate change
take place on our television screens in
our newspaper headlines I do the
sabbatical early this year down in
Australia where I literally watched the
impacts the dangerous and catastrophic
impacts of climate change play out in
real time in the form of unprecedented
bush fires and California where this
event is based of course you have seen
unprecedented wildfires as well in
recent years and it's not rocket science
you take heat and drought both of them
exacerbated by the warming of the planet
caused by fossil fuel burning and other
carbon emissions you take that heat you
combine it with drought you get
unprecedented wildfires and as we're
learning as we continue to understand in
greater detail some of the complexities
about how climate change works we're
finding that in fact the impacts are
playing out in many respects faster and
with a greater magnitude than our models
predicted just a decade or so ago and
that means the ice sheets which are
losing ice earlier and so sea level is
rising faster and we're seeing the
behavior of the jet stream change in
ways that our models haven't really
predicted that give us those extreme
very stationary weather systems that
associated with catastrophic extreme
weather events like the bush bars and
wildfires that I mentioned like the
unprecedented floods and heat waves and
droughts and super storms that we have
seen play out in recent years so we
don't have to use too much imagination
to to envision what our future could
look like
or we could indeed take a course if we
don't act if we don't act on this
problem if we continue with business as
usual burning of fossil fuels and we
warm the planet 3 maybe 4 degrees
Celsius by the end of the century 7 8 9
degrees potentially Fahrenheit by the
end of the century then the worst
impacts that we've seen thus far will
become commonplace the hottest day that
we've ever experienced we will just call
that summer um that's one possible
future that is a dystopian future the
good news here is that we hold the
future within our own hands
if we act dramatically if we shift away
from fossil fuels if we bring those
carbon emissions down as I said by a
factor or two over the next ten years
which is possible with policies that
incentivize a shift away from fossil
fuels towards renewable energy if we
incentivize the decarbonisation of our
economy then we can keep the warming to
a level where yes you know we will be
dealing with a new normal the things
that we have been experienced the you
know precedented weather disasters that
we've experienced the flooding of our
coastlines there's no way to really
reverse that but we can adapt to those
changes if we mitigate further warming
of the planet but if we don't mitigate
that warming if we continue with
business as usual then it's not
inappropriate to liken what we will see
to the sorts of futures that Hollywood
has portrayed the sorts of dystopian
futures that that Hollywood has
envisioned though that's a possible
future it's in our hands it's up to us
Michael I'm going to ask the panel to
respond to you but before they do can I
ask if you've been able to put the
pandemic into your models and how has it
changed has it changed what you're
seeing yes or the pandemic
is sort of an interesting experiment
that that is playing out in real time
what we're seeing is that the sort of
lockdown and social distancing policies
that we put in place to deal with the
pandemic is actually impacting our
carbon emissions it's bringing on our
carbon emissions down the estimates are
in now that we'll probably see a four to
seven percent decrease in our annual
carbon emissions by you know for this
year because of the lockdown now that
might seem like reason for optimism
until I tell you that we need at least
that much and maybe a 15 percent
reduction in carbon emissions every year
for the next decade if we are with any
degree of confidence to limit warming
but beyond those dangerous thresholds
and so yes changing our behavior not
traveling and the sort of social
distancing and lock down activities that
we've seen play out in recent months
those changes in our lives and our
personal behavior our individual
behavior it can impact our carbon
emissions it can bring them down a bit
but in order to see the wholesale shift
that we really need from fossil
fuel-burning to renewable energy the
decarbonisation of our economy we need
systemic change we need policies that
will incentivize that shift away from
business as usual because individual
action alone as we've seen from the
pandemic now isn't enough to get us the
carbon emissions cuts that we need okay
Carmen could I begin by asking either of
you to respond to Michael thoughts on
energy I can I can go on this one I've
been thinking a lot about systemic
changes and whether our moment right now
creates imperatives for us to really
address the root causes of the crises
that are overwhelming our nation and the
planet at this moment looking for
instance systemically at the
intersections between racial injustice
intergenerational injustice economic
policies the climate changes you've just
described where would that kind of
systemic thinking occur and will it
address the radical roots of all of this
in time to create effective policies
yeah thanks Carol it's a great question
and it would be remiss for us not to be
talking about you know what is playing
out right now the crisis that we're
seeing of course there's the climate
crisis there's the pandemic and now we
have a crisis with our democracy where
we're seeing a different sort of
lockdown or a push back against you know
an uprising of citizens who are speaking
out about the injustice is that we have
you know that we become all too familiar
with and so there is sort of a field or
almost a movement known as climate
justice which recognizes sort of the
intersectionality of all these things
that ultimately climate change is one of
the greatest forms of social and racial
injustice that there is because it turns
out that the negative impacts are going
to fall disproportionately on those with
the least resources and so it is a
matter of justice of intergenerational
justice racial justice and we have
arrived at this you know we've heard
this term you so often now that it's
becoming hackneyed a perfect storm but
we let's face it we are seeing this
perfect storm of things factors that are
coming together to lead us I think maybe
to the point and Barack Obama basically
said this in a speech to the nation
yesterday to lead us to the point where
maybe we're ready to reinvigorate a
better world whether we're talking about
environmental sustainability or basic
issues of societal justice racial
justice intergenerational justice we
have this unique moment in time and I'm
hoping that we take advantage of it you
to add your thoughts you know so
well I want to thank you for the
opportunity my background is I spent 32
years at CIA as a analytic officer and a
manager of analysts say three things one
the question of models so I know from
talking to people my peers colleagues
trying to convince them friends and exes
that the coronavirus in covert 19 was
real
they still many of them doubt it that
models are not persuasive to a wide
swath of people and then in fact models
can be flawed as as Michael pointed out
the changes in the jet stream were not
predicted by the model so I think an
attempt to mobilize the world around
models which I think the movement has
been doing attempting to for a while has
its limits so that's that's my first
point - I was struck by Michaels point
that we would have to achieve and I I
didn't write it down so I don't remember
it exactly but we would have to achieve
a 15% reduction for the rest of the
decade earlier what per year what mine
was then we have to have this year for
the rest of the decade over and over and
over again yeah which one has equity and
justice implications - just strikes me
as practical you know unless in fact the
pathetic in a second why wave is you
know a couple of times worse than the
Spanish flu seems unachievable so and
then so my third point is to deal with
climate change and all the other issues
we face I think that we're going to have
to find a positive thing for people to
rally around positive and inclusive
rather than negative and scary what am I
heuristic devices about how people think
is that people tend to believe
worst-case scenarios are unlikely you're
seeing this play out with the pandemic
and no matter how much you warn people
of what's happening I think that they're
gonna dismiss it and frankly I don't
think we have enough trust interpersonal
trust not only in our society but across
the planet for us to be able to mobilize
against a great negative because that
requires sacrifice from everyone so
somehow we have to flip this and I don't
know how so that it is a more positive
conversation about moving to someplace
better and my last comment and I do have
some hope that in if the corona virus
and the pandemic really creates a
significant drag on world economy for
more than one year that people will
realize that the green you deal for
example in a kind of cynical way is the
best way to restart the economy that no
it's the economy suffers so much that
you can't really get it going again
unless you engage in something dramatic
and big to restart it getting good can I
ask you denigrate okay can I ask you
whether you believe there's a path for
the United States back into the climate
community feared so and please introduce
yourself I'm sorry Cara Lee next time
you speak I'll ask you to introduce
yourself but before you get going well
the most important thing is I was class
of 67 at Stanford but beyond that I've
done other things since then but I did
stuff on us-china relations for about 40
years and consultant with the US
government on that and then worked with
the National Intelligence Council not as
a member of the government but as an
outside consultant on the global
long-term global trends in the Knik
global trans reports which I think are
very important I mean certainly Carolyn
and Carmen know them
well so that's led me to real interest
in long-term trends and the impact of
Technology exponential technologies on
society so I think that first of all I
think that in the next six eight months
our world historically critical period
may be the most important decisive point
and since World War two perhaps because
we could go one path which recede is
intended by the current administration
and if that continues I think we would
have a very difficult time in
transitioning to really meet the
challenges that Michael's talked about
Carol and Carmen and I I just don't see
it I think we're headed potentially even
towards a very autocratic regime and
dismantlement even more of our
scientific capability and particularly
in government so but on the other hand
we have the opportunity if we change and
Biden as president I think he's gonna
you know could take us in a very
different path and go I think Carmen's
mentioned the green new deal is right on
the money that we have to have a
positive vision by kind of no regrets
policy that you're doing things that are
good whether or not you believe in
climate change and I've always felt that
the biggest thing that nobody ever seems
to talk about about energy green energy
is that the fuel is free forever
you're never again gonna have to pay
Texas or Saudi Arabia the import fuel
and keep it's like a addicts everyday
you paid for this fuel why not have it
be free and that makes a huge difference
in the global economy and certainly in
the economy of a state or a city so I
think we have a possibility of moving in
a very different direction that makes a
lot of sense to people and could be sold
as a vision and I think we you know
there's a lot of things we can do that
will be the green economy that will put
people to jobs I'm for more more
production of food and in cities and
then the rural areas around them and
technology can really lead us to do that
in a much more efficient and inclusive
way that's a lot of jobs more production
of goods the 3d printing and other
things more at the point of consumption
rather than moving Goods all over the
world I can see a very different economy
that has a lot of benefits to us but not
so beneficial to the petro States and
reduces the global impact of all of our
on me and yet offers a lot of jobs and a
lot of way forward so I think the the
vision the vision thing is what we
really need and but there there are
paths forward that are very beneficial
across the board and in dealing with
climate justice as Michael put it and
and jobs and inclusivity but it's going
to take you know the question is can we
restore faith in government in experts
and the fact that we need government
we've created it for a reason and we
need it and we've shown through the
complete failure of our health system to
be ready for this pandemic and not
putting putting aside the leadership
that's also failed as well that we
there's a lot we need to do but there
may be public support for it as a result
of what we've seen in this pandemic the
health of everybody is important
everybody else
maybe we need universal health coverage
for me to be secure not just out of
compassion and concern for others you
know the public health started and as I
understand in New York when the rich
people were getting sick but from the
immigrants that brought collar and they
said oh we maybe we don't want those
people to get sick those we're gonna
work for me and and get me sick so maybe
there's a sea change and how people look
at the health of others and the need for
universal health care and then there's
basic income there's all these things
have been brought before and now we see
that the the racial dimension of this is
is incredible and and and so a key to
this country's future and and so I are
we gonna address that well I think we
have the possibility it again it depends
on the next six months then you look at
the America's position in the world and
we're headed towards you know little
America alone being ridiculed by the
world and but more importantly the
geopolitical collapse into a kind of
zero-sum strategic competition rather
than putting cooperation first and the
US emerge again to be it take a while to
really build trust that we are the
necessary leader in climate change and
on pandemics on science and global
cooperating global cooperation ahead of
the competition we could do that we have
the potential I think maybe the world
will they'll be distrustful for
long time we could have another Trump
someday but I think they want us to lead
we need were the ones that were the
essential partner there and we have to
work with the Chinese figure how to do
this so we have a whole agenda of things
that we're headed again you know we can
go one way where we don't we don't even
set the foundation for for the kind of
alternative futures that we all want to
see or we can really move forward and
maybe leapfrog because people are ready
to move much faster now than they ever
would have been before the Komen crisis
so it's like I said I think we're in
this really inflection point it could go
either way and and if it goes the way
that I hope it goes then I think we have
a real potential to do to reimagine to
do new things to do really bold things
FDR level things so I think it's you
know we have this a conversation January
20th it will be very different maybe
before I go one thing you said sort of
sparked a question in my mind yeah we
both came from grew up at a time where
in 1968 as a period in time was very
influential on us and I was wondering if
you see any echoes of 1968 in the in the
coming summer if you will well I think
that one difference is at that point on
foreign policy we had you know the Cold
War consensus basically we didn't have
the deep divisions that we have now and
I think even our part you know we had
bipartisanship in Congress in responding
to various crises and things we don't
have that I mean I think in many ways
we're in a deeper deeper well at this
point than we were even in 68 and
believe me I was up you know about there
in the in the streets with with John
about the Vietnam War no but I think
this is this is even more of an
inflection point we could go in a very
much worse direction because unleashed
this administration just imagine what
could happen but if we have the
opportunity maybe we can build a new
consensus but it's certainly the riots
and that you know the reaction to it we
had the assassination but an
assassination of Kennedy and and MLK and
then the Tet Offensive and the collapse
of the Vietnam policy a lot of things
going on there
and we were all very concerned about it
but I I think this is in many ways maybe
worse
in terms of the potential impact where
we might be in a year is much more
positive possibility maybe but also very
very negative and I'm optimistic but I
think there's a lot of a lot of bad
things are gonna happen between now and
January myself I'm begging I'm glad
you're in one place now I was I was
worried about asking you questions when
I thought you might crash can you
introduce yourself and also I wanted to
ask you you're the most I think the most
recent refugee from the government I
wanted to ask you about the possibility
of a path for the United States back
into being a world citizen do you see a
path so um thank you John and really
resonate with what everybody is talking
about and I'm gonna go to that question
but the first thing I'm gonna do
especially because we're talking about
climate and I think we need to think in
systems ways I want to actually do a
land acknowledgement that I've learned
from Native American leaders and youth
that we acknowledge the planet were on
and and the people who were here first
and a genius indigenious knowledge that
they have that we could learn from to
work on not only climate but community
benefits focused um culture and not
necessarily profit culture but community
benefit profit can be part of community
benefit certainly it's a business model
and you know here in DC where I live the
Powhatan tribes that has got away
Connelly others and wherever we are
physically in who was here first and how
did they think and how might we go back
to the future together in order to
understand and be thinking in good ways
and I think it's interesting also to
notice exactly what's happening right
now and there's two things it's it's
great you mentioned 1968 1969 we just
celebrated an incredible launch of the
first commercial space
- you send astronaut up to the space
station that's happening simultaneously
with the inequality protests with this
horrific murder in Minneapolis at Fort
Floyd and a Britannian of Rihanna and
the other people who have you know we
can say their names we need skating
names and I wanted to bring this forward
um if you can see it this was a tweet
out of the King Center right privileges
is saying you know privilege is when you
think something is not a problem because
you might person affected personally and
I think we have a lot of imbalance on in
the National Academy of Engineering um
any things we list the Grand Challenges
for the future
you know for a young people to work on
him we leave out justice because it's
not an engineering and science problem
it's a problem of any tool of the
universe and it's with us right this
moment because I to be Wells just won
the Pulitzer Prize now Ida is one of the
greatest American data scientists
journalists who worked over a hundred
years ago on the same challenge that
people on the streets on in this case on
lynching and the lies the same thing is
the birdwatcher you know calling the
police on people that's a lie and so how
does this relate to climate I think the
disrespect of talent and the respect of
some talent the imbalance of who gets
the play is really hurting us all
because there's so many genius people
who would cancer solve climate whatever
but they don't get the job you know they
get passed over because of long-standing
systemic oppression and bias you know in
the 60s Katherine Johnson was calculate
factories for John Glenn and the Apollo
11 mission you know an african-american
woman mathematician genius you know she
she you there's a great video for you
know you can tell the math is still in
her mind and she did we lost her
recently but she's talking about where
that moon would be when they get there
and people really did this that really
have
but I never saw her in a movie you know
and so we thought one group does it one
group doesn't and then the one group who
does have credits think there and the
savior solver of the other rather than
just look around so one of the things I
learned in government was to just start
looking around for who had already fixed
the problem or had something promising I
caught Scout and scale and specific and
climbing the phone genius people over
the world we did this with the UN we
just asked on the web who's already
fixed the sustainable development goals
who's already been who's who's working
on this already and just like in Silicon
Valley the venture capitalists don't
make the companies they find at Bezos
even musk there's agreed these people
you know and I Steve Jobs so let's find
more people and come up underneath them
I'm the co-founder the Malala fund cuz
Malala would be the best person in the
world to help us get girls to education
to lead us and then all of us can join
her you see that vision so I think that
because of systemic bias we did things
like forgot to have tech in the room in
our government in all meetings just like
we would have a lawyer or a Surgeon
General or communicating with others so
civic tech is encouraging right now cuz
it's growing nonprofit philanthropic
tech that I to be well as in data
science in the Department of Justice
would be just as important as data
science at NASA and that you know tech
doesn't come later it's part of the
architecture and certainly tech is a
very arrogant we're all arrogant you
know we're just gonna fix it with our
tech but it's not about that it's about
the harder problems of the world um one
of my favorite examples of one of the
hardest data science problems to solve
right this minute is feeding children
free and reduced lunch when they're not
in school
we have 22 to 30 million children who
get free and reduced lunch and then in
the summer we only feed 6 million and
yet somehow a self-driving car is more
important to work on which is a big data
problem right like and I don't mean or I
mean and let's work on that and that's
do it and so the last thing I would
share just in this particular comment is
this I tweeted out this story there's
rest abernathy again
this is the summer of 69 at the Apollo
11 launch most people don't know that
the same group that did the march on
Washington in 68 we were talking about
68 protested the Apollo 11 launch and
the head of NASA came to the perimeter
to sit with Ralph and Ralph said you
know a great nation ought to be able to
take care of those who are less
fortunate as well as undertake space
exploration not only that you know tech
for foster care tech for school lunch a
tech civic tech nonprofit tech but also
how about all the talent gets to do what
it would do and include it and we use
technology you know we've been working
with USC and another Geena Davis
Institute on using face recognition and
natural language processing on media
bias because we see one group all the
time do everything and then the other
group isn't so you know how do we change
our media so that we here are more of
the voices and we realized that Ada
Lovelace invented computer science the
same time Darwin thought of the history
of us she thought of the future of us I
wish to bequeath to the generations a
calculus of the nervous system 1840s
yeah that's great thank you very good I
want to bring in another force or factor
we talked about climate but I want to
ask both Tennessee impulsed affo about
Moore's law
you know Silicon Valley thrived on Wars
law for 60 years now and it transformed
the entire world during that period but
starting in 2014 2015 and I'm the
pessimist here I began to see parts of
that machine begin to slow down and
perhaps stop I mean the cost of
transistors stuff stop falling in 2015
and Moore's law was defined not just by
increasing exponentially increasing
computer power but exponentially falling
costs which created these new industries
or made it possible let me start with
asking jinan what if I'm right what if
wars law is stole for some significant
period I think you are largely right
John I think that can combined with the
failure of what's called parents
which says that the energy use also fell
as the transistor count a knock so that
what happened was computers got more
powerful while taking less energy or the
same amount and both those trends have
have ceased better Dennard scaling much
more abruptly a Moore's law sort of on
the last tale I think of it as slowing
down I don't think there's anybody who
realistically believes they're going to
reinvent Moore's law and recapture what
we were used to
so that says we have to think very
differently about computing you Bertie's
seen this shift to the kinds of things
that Nvidia and Google are doing to
build processors which are which achieve
much greater efficiencies but for
narrower tasks so I think we're gonna
have to give up on the concept that
we're gonna get truly general-purpose of
performance breakthroughs like we're
used to and look for alternative
mechanisms there's one other comment
I'll make on this and that's there's a
recent paper by Charles lysis and Butler
Lampson and who that of MIT called
there's plenty of room at the top which
analyzes the way in which we do software
production right now lots of people call
them Python for example and they take a
piece of Python code and then gradually
transform it into C C++ and optimize it
for the machine and in the end their
final piece of code runs 60,000 times
faster than the original Python code so
a way of thinking about this is because
hardware was making so much progress we
in the software industry naturally said
let's move the let's move our
programming paradigms up the abstraction
level make it easier for people to build
code but much less efficient we may have
to go back and recapture some of that
whether it's by new programming model
there's an opportunity that we're gonna
have to exploit thank you
this John was president of Stanford his
chair of Google and he's the co-author
of a wonderful text on computer
architecture Paul can I can I post a
photo can I put the same question to you
the consequences I I can't decide what
would be a bigger problem if Moore's Law
start stalling out or if Moore's Law
stop stalling and continues accelerating
it's the the issue isn't Moore's Law the
issue is the growing gap between how our
culture adapts and how fast our
technologies are advancing so we have an
exponential part of our lives and the
technology sphere and we have a non
exponential part yet a at a cultural
level and in a way this conversation to
me feels a little bit like a microcosm
of what's going on globally that where
we're standing on a whale distracted by
minnows you know when I think back to
the pandemic I'm of the opinion that the
the virus is of absolutely no
consequence it is the response that we
have had in my career as a forecaster
and I've worked as a forecaster some
would call me a futurist in the valley
for 30 years you you might call me a
futurist with a past and I teach at
Stanford that there are two events in my
professional career that have been
absolutely anticipated more than
anything else and one of them is the
pandemic we all knew it was coming and
the problem is that we underly failed to
respond and I find that profoundly
depressing because the only other event
that has been more predicted than the
pandemic is of course climate change so
in that sense it really has nothing to
do with technology what what we're
seeing is quite simply put the pandemic
as a test and human humankind is failing
it we are in the midst of an
anthropological crisis and it ain't
going to be
with technology it is not going to be
fixed at the national level you know the
United States as a certain French
Minister said to me over coffee about 10
years ago he happens to be the French
president now it says the u.s. too big
to ignore too weak to make a difference
let me throw this out to the panel as a
whole you know the United States has
clearly stepped off the world stage for
the moment what about China would
somebody like to address the role of
China over the next 30 years will China
be the neck of the world's next
superpower raise your hand or start
speaking I'm happy to since I yeah
because it relates to you know how we
started the conversation climate change
and right now we're actually seeing the
u.s. as you've alluded to as we've all
loaded to sort of we're losing
leadership when it comes to issues like
tackling climate change in fact the
current administration has threatened to
be the only country in the world to
actually withdraw from the Paris
agreement so we're going in the wrong
direction and we're seeing the Trump
administration dismantle environmental
protections that were put in place by
the Nixon administration by the Bush
administration by the Reagan
administration that's how quickly we're
moving in the wrong direction and that
vacuum of leadership on issues like
climate in that vacuum we are seeing
countries like China one of the
interesting things about a sort of
command and control country like China
is that it can act quickly and
deliberately when it comes to these
sorts of major challenges and that is
certainly the case when it comes to the
issue of climate change where China is
actually now leading the world when it
comes to the manufacturing of solar
panels wind solar they are spending more
they're developing technology that the
rest of the world is benefiting from in
the renewable energy space and they were
actually on course to dismantle
coal-fired power plants China was not
only not building new coal-fired power
plants they were dismantling coal-fired
power plants and then a couple years ago
well actually now nearly four years ago
we elected or the Electoral College put
in place a president who in fact
signaled to the rest of the world that
the United States one of the two largest
emitters of carbon in the world was not
willing to meet its obligations and that
took the pressure off of China and we've
actually seen China sort of pull back a
little bit they started to build some
new coal-fired power plants and they're
not moving as quickly in the direction
that we need to go because of it so you
know as we alluded to previously in this
conversation
what is so vital about this moment in
time is that in a matter of months we
have the opportunity to choose to go in
a completely different direction to
regain our stature as a leader when it
comes to issues like climate change to
join the world community and to set an
example and create incentives for
countries like China to jointly engage
in this effort to you know preserve the
livability of this plan it's no lesser a
challenge than the challenge to preserve
the livability of this planet caroler
carbon do your thoughts on China I
wanted to make a comment yes on China
thank you John one is I just want to one
comment this let's be cautious about the
vocabulary that we use so the word
superpower what does that really mean
given the range of threats or issues
challenges that we're facing in the
future
what is China a superpower about I mean
it's just a term that when you use it
people think they know what it means but
there is no consensus on what that term
really means and the importance of that
concept anymore in the world affairs the
second thing I will say about China and
this returns back to my point about
positivity being a more powerful force
galvanizing force and negativity
the one thing that China
has it all over the US right now is a
sense of social unity its frame and of
course it's supported undergirded by a
very clever system of social monitoring
and control but my experience was when
you talk to Chinese citizens that they
will say something like I know that
we're not much of a democracy right now
but we're headed in the right direction
and we're making a more powerful society
and I think that is something which the
US has lost and sadly may continue to
lose depending upon actually regardless
of who wins the election we may still
find ourselves lacking the social
cohesion to deal with difficult problems
caryl thoughts on China well I'd like to
take it in a little different direction
but you asked me to introduce myself
first
like like Carmen I spent 33 years in the
US intelligence community almost all of
it at the CIA as an analyst but also in
the Department of Energy looking at
energy and environmental security issues
I designed and taught a course on global
climate change and global security which
I taught after retiring and I've been
looking at lately coping 19 futures and
their implications for the US with
regard to China my brain kind of goes to
the global challenges we all face koban
19 being one of them and we can look as
Paul said to the reaction which has been
very concerning nations have basically
turned inward at a time when we still
have a lot of globe-spanning challenges
in fact most of the challenges we face
if we want to call them security issues
we can but they're also just human
living issues they're they're global in
nature I've been doing some thinking
about how we might look back on our
times let's say
thirty four forty years from now and I'm
I'm kind of captivated by the idea of
what happened in the 18th century with
the so-called Enlightenment which in you
know in turn was a reaction to the
biggest natural disaster Europe had has
experienced even to this day it was a
design was one of the factors I should
say and that was the Lisbon earthquake
and there are a lot of Europeans today
that don't even know there was an
earthquake in 1755 but a lot of the
intellectuals at the time started to
wrestle with well how could an
earthquake like that occur in a world
where everything that happens happens
because God wanted it to happen why and
there's a bigger story there but I see
the brexit and the election of 2016 in
the US as sort of our earthquake and if
I were imagining how we might look on
our on our century right now some
decades ahead we're going to have to see
the world in a very different way we're
going to have to read think man's place
in the natural world in a way that
radically builds or maybe shifts from
the findings of the Enlightenment and a
lot of the things that people have said
so far today are pieces of that
including what Meghan was talking about
we're going to have to have a new
appraisal you know the whole
Anthropocene knowledge about how we're
basically living on a different planet
already with the co2 co2 emissions
higher than they've ever been in human
history
I'm not sure where all this thinking is
going to happen everything here so far
today has been pretty interdisciplinary
but I'm not sure where the epicenter of
this is going to be but whether we can
think systemically about how these
things interconnect will determine you
know whether humanity survives and I
don't mean mankind as a species but I
mean the idea of humanity I think by
2030 could be gone if we don't reopen at
Schweinfurt
the original question to Michael Mann
thank you I wanted to bring up a couple
of other sort of forcing functions or
large forces in the world one of them
you know Silicon Valley was driven by
immigration is driven by immigration
it's been a magnet for the best in the
brightest and I actually believe very
deeply that that is one of the reasons
that Silicon Valley is what it is I
wouldn't ask Paul about you know we're
on the brink of ending immigration you
know nationally and perhaps to Silicon
Valley what does that do to Silicon
Valley and you know I guess the larger
question here is in the next 30 years
where is the center of innovation in the
world are there centers does it change
in some significant way Paul well you
know it was
Annalee saxenian who famously said
Silicon Valley has not spread out
widened Li but packed closely together
and that's why people bump into each
other and start companies and to
innovation and so really the question is
is not which particular region will
succeed but rather where will people
spend most of their time bumping into
each other and all the indicators are
that increasingly that'll be in
cyberspace and it's it's clear that
we're we're poised on the edge of
another social media shift it'll come
out in the next three and a half years
it's going to make the cyber cyberspace
experience as a social space even more
vivid so I think the short answer it's
the it's going to start in cyberspace
and then they will it will land in the
physical regions that are most amenable
to supporting startups and like so I see
a lot of competition around the planet
for for brains going forward in the next
30 years Megan first yeah I don't know
if I could screen share but I'd love to
show you some images of what this could
look like
if that's an option does that see if
this is working I'm gonna screen sure do
you guys see that yeah okay cool so one
of the things I think you know I said
there's talent everywhere we did this
solution some of the United Nations and
looking at who already was doing the
SDGs who's already doing this and we got
it the first year we've done in five
years I like eight hundred swishes last
year 1,400 submissions from 141
countries in three weeks BAM right Wow
and so you know instead of only the
folks who get to know how to contact a
VC or philanthropy this is a really
broad group of people it's a live
spreadsheet it's an open process my
co-founder is Susan Dawson who led
public engagement um was the architect
of how we do that and just genius people
it's gender balance geo balance to talk
about these are some of the innovators
you know flying drones to plant a
billion trees a year solving prison
challenges people in Uganda doing that
themselves so the one I would point out
just as an example is the floating Fab
Lab from Benin Juarez who grew up in the
Amazon he's his indigenous community
there what if we have a maker space
floating Fab Lab instead of having cut
down the trees job you know in this
capacity for human capacity to do their
thing so thinking about all the doers
whether it's their students and their
learning practice makes permanent or
that or everyone else so this is this
example I wanted to show you like
Bernice in the middle there's from Ghana
she grows bikes she literally makes
bamboo bikes cuz they don't have a
strong a steel industry and so here's a
way to sequester carbon and right it's
half women building beautiful designs
and I found metal as well new metal it's
like every ten they give one away to a
school child all over the country you
know here she is with a mentorship
ecosystem like we know from Silicon
Valley with a people who can be
accelerators of her but she would never
get that unless we reach out to her you
know and she's got this wonderful
company we could do that ever here's
Native American innovators from Pine
Ridge one of the poorest counties in
nine states Henry R ed Clapp solar
genius rose with agriculture innovation
so MIT
as a program that we work on with our
ship 17 finding standing our Pine Ridge
Navajo genius doers whose silken value I
love my old colleagues but like they
never go here and they never ask what
you got they wait for everyone to come
you know and then there's so much what
these people could use an innovation
this is island innovators we work with
the polynesian voyaging society and some
of the colleagues there gluts by global
island partnership they are now doing
video calls from innovators who are
already working and you seen i know
there on the screen he led the team from
the Hokulea think the movie Moana this
is human intelligence at a time of
intelligent artificial intelligence
humans can actually sail with no
instruments not even a compass around
the world that's so amazing and here's
some of the young navigators who are
learning you know when we in the White
House we held a tech meetup of all the
meetup organizers in our country who are
already bringing tech to their
communities and bridging like ratchet
tech is an old rec center in Baltimore
that has tech nano mega little kids big
kids genius solutions and this is the
tech job Stuart people you know just
community organizing themselves into the
new future like a future of inclusive
work Boise Idaho Gaza Afghanistan
there's so much activity but no
neighbors now and the policy colleagues
didn't know so there's really an
opportunity to take place and cohorting
and all the stuff that we know is out
there and and make that happen all stop
screen sharing now but I just wanted to
study infuse some enthusiasm for us for
the opportunity opportunistic or the
opportunity of like inclusive innovation
and really using our best of community
organizing with our best of innovation
techniques and our best of listening and
design thinking to come up underneath
the genius colleagues of our seven
billion colleagues on the world and
listen for who's there my last example
that I'll give you is in Los Angeles
Jean home who works for mayor Garcetti
and is a data science faculty member at
UCLA
created the data sign Federation so
right now sometimes we talk about how
we're gonna get more kids into coding
and that she just took the data sets of
the city which don't always get as much
mention as some of other datasets and
she assigned she gets the city teams to
list problems and then young people as
part of their homework work on like
we're going to your hometown for your
work they work on data prototypes for
the city it's real projects what-if fun
way to learn computer science as a
college or high school student to work
on a topic in your city like justice or
transport or homelessness and then come
into thinking of peer colleagues more is
where I'm getting and respecting the
talent on the planet we could really
move faster on innovation if we increase
our surface area and really get rid of
some of our biases and structural
inequities thank you Michael you know in
the chat stream I've seen fusion and
nuclear come up a couple of times and I
wanted to ask your view broadly about
this transition that you're talking
about that we need to make and whether
nuclear will play a role in your view um
well you know here at Stanford or there
at Stanford as a colleague of mine Marc
Jacobson who's one of the leading
experts in the world when it comes to
sort of the renewable energy transition
and what it will take to decarbonize our
economy and and he has published you
know peer-reviewed work that
demonstrates a very clear path forward
to achieving carbon neutrality by 2050
getting most of the way there by 2030 by
simply scaling up and incentivizing
existing renewable energy now and in
that it's without nuclear technology now
when it comes to nuclear energy so we
have to distinguish between fusion and
fission conventional nuclear energy
being fission fusion which seems to be
always ten years around the corner we're
always told that we're about ten years
from viable fusion energy and it turns
out what really is necessary for it to
be viable isn't just that you get more
energy out than you put in you've got to
get about ten times as much energy out
than you put in for it to be
economically competitive with other
sources of energy so Fusion is elusive
much as we might like it to be part of
the solution because it would be a clean
nuclear technology on the other hand
conventional nuclear energy a few
fission nuclear energy comes with all
sorts of potential pitfalls problems
when it comes to proliferation and
conflict environmental contamination and
we've seen very vivid examples of that
of course I'm within an hour and a half
of Three Mile Island there was a very
famous nuclear meltdown decades ago
reminding us of the environmental threat
that comes from nuclear so every thing
we do when it comes to you know there's
no way to to have no environmental
footprint when you're trying to provide
energy for nearly eight billion in
growing people and an increasingly
energy intensive civilization everything
we do comes with an environmental
footprint renewable energy comes with an
environmental footprint and there's a
larger problem that we have to contend
with which is how we live sustainably on
this planet but when it comes to the
climate change problem what we need to
do is simply decarbonize our economy and
we can get there with renewable energy
it's just a matter of you know we let me
for example challenge Bill Gates when he
says we need a miracle
we don't need a miracle it's already
there it's the Sun it's the wind its
geothermal we have the necessary
technologies we just need policies that
incentivize that we're already moving in
that direction the problem is we're not
moving fast enough to get those
emissions reductions we need to avert
catastrophic warming we need to
accelerate that transition that means
subsidies incentives for renewable
energy and that means some sort of price
on carbon
we need an externality that you know you
can't dump carbon pollution into the
atmosphere at no cost because it's
having a negative impact on the planet
so it's not rocket science we know what
the solutions are we just need
policymakers who are willing to
implement them and once again it brings
me back to the same place in a matter of
months we have an opportunity to elect a
president who will actually act on our
behalf including policies you know
support policies that you know reflect
our interests rather than the polluting
interests who currently govern the Trump
administration I want to get at least
one more issue on the table at this
juncture would anybody like to talk
about religion as a force in the world
over the next three decades I'm curious
about whether it will be more of a force
or less Paul well I'm on record is
saying we're way overdue for a major new
religion
hundreds of religions start every year
but most don't stick
Nietzsche put it nicely when he said
nearly 2,000 years and no new God
and I think it's really clear we are
we're in a new moment not unlike Karl
Jasper's axial age where there's a
crisis of belief as I said earlier this
is an anthropological crisis it's not
technological it's not virus based we
are in an anthropological crisis and and
really the task over the next couple of
decades is to figure out how to create a
global civilization and that could well
be something that comes out of religion
and there are lots of places religion
can come out of an obvious one is an
environmental religion but there are
lots of other ways as well do you see
any policy threads do you see any shoots
anything promising oh yeah there is I've
been I've been chasing this for well
over a decade and there is lots of
really interesting stuff but it's it's
all a little bit weird and hard to
describe in a couple of sound bites I
would just say that a belief in the
environment you know the gyeom theory is
the logical place were to happen but to
keep in mind there and you know I think
I forget if it was Carroll domain or who
who mentioned the the 1755 quake of
Lisbon on which happened on All Saints
Day of course
and it did create the opening for the
Enlightenment because it left the soccer
dog days in such stunned silence for a
couple of years if the philosophers were
able to to jump in and and I think this
is this is a moment like that we we just
need a focal event that that will
trigger it you say that sort of to say
the crazy thing out loud I think one of
the focal points could be some proof
that we're not alone in the universe
I actually did a tweet a few years ago
and I my bet is by 2050 that there will
be I don't know what it will look like
but there will be some thing that will
be very persuasive for a lot of people
that there's something much broader than
humanity and this planet and I'm not
necessarily saying a god but I think
that the religion you know ackley most
religions a key aspect is that we human
beings are somehow special compared to
all the other stuff in the universe and
I think discovering some other stuff in
the universe would really erode that and
so I think that that's you know a
possible focal point just to bend the
religion question a little bit what I
what I believe is very important and a
huge factor is the loss of meaning in
people's lives I think that that fuel
much of the support behind Trump I think
it exists particularly in mature Western
societies that have become rather tired
and divided at the same time and I think
and and and so many of the things that
provided meaning in people's lives
religion work family have been corrupted
have been eroded recently although
perhaps one
benefit of the pandemic is a resurgence
of family life so I'll just stop right
there because I see people have are
raising their hands any first and then
Paul banning you did you want to say
something yeah yeah a couple of things
what I think what Carmen said very very
interesting comment on second first of
all the company Koba 19 crisis is the
first I think it's the first global
crisis in human history where virtually
every person and every country on the
planet is affected by this
unlike even world war two for there
plenty of people to set it out so this
is a very interesting phenomena and the
thumb and bottom line of course is that
it's a global challenge we have to solve
it together if you don't deal with it
for everybody then it's gonna come back
and get you and if your America first so
that's an interesting point the second
thing I would say is that any global
religion that we're talking about has to
believe in science and has to believe in
facts and has to believe in some kind of
notion of her common humanity that our
common humanity comes before our
particular tribe I think those three
things and then and and we're all part
of this earth we're all connected to it
a Humboldt in view you know that was
really under underlies Gaia you so I
think that that has to be part of it if
it's gonna be successful to save human
civilization than be able to focus
ourselves on climate change
environmental degradation all that list
of issues that we know we face that are
potentially catastrophic so I think
those it can't be a messianic religion I
don't think and I just as a maybe a
point of humor but I really been
reminded of in the movie Independence
Day you know that we face this
unfortunately it was aliens who were
threatening so I'm not advocating
threatening aliens but we facing a
threat to the entire world civilization
and by the way it was a scientist
computer scientist who figures out the
problem and ironically of course the
solution was to inject the virus into
the mothership but it was all you know
the end of course the thing that's
almost ludicrous today it was led by the
United States right
that's not happening but it ultimately
was they when they figured out what to
do they sent out by Morse code to all
the armies around the world how to bring
them down how to defeat this thing look
call let's call it a virus rather than
call it an alien invasion but it
required a global effort and the
scientists figured it out let it and
then we made a global response to the
global challenge so that I mean that's a
very strange I think may be a metaphor
for where we are today but I do think it
that's the kind of challenge we face how
can we believe together and trust each
other enough on a global sense that
whatever our differences are the
challenges are greater and we have to
cooperate to do it and how can we leave
that as an idea you know ideology and
philosophy whatever or a religion Oh
Paul did you want to add something yeah
I would not overstate what will happen
when we find evidence of intelligent
life elsewhere in the universe if we
should my forecast is very simple if we
do find unequivocal evidence of such a
thing
one third of humanity will want to
convert it one third of humanity will
want to conquer it and one third of
humanity will want to sell it something
I I don't think it will have a big
impact on religion what it will have a
big impact on is our view of space you
know this is this is a moment with space
but it's not unlike Senecas famous
prediction and Medea the overcome an age
in the far future when an ocean shall
unloose its bonds in essence the ocean
ceases to be a barrier becomes a highway
I also really disagree with banning
about religion the it would be nice if
it was an idealistic religion but
equally likely is that we have a
response against science and technology
and it becomes the new ghost dance a
global crisis cult but you know maybe
not so
to you to your point Paul with it and
one-third will want to eat it I'll have
to change that 25% yes we should all do
not forget the Twilight Zone episode to
serve mankind yeah I was just gonna say
I really resonate with Cartman and
others um I think that one thing I
wanted to validate was the note in the
chat of sort of male-dominated
misogynist religion like just someone
shouted that out and and you know sort
of racism sexism all the isms it's Pride
Month and and that there's a really
interesting quote that I popped in the
chat from ads in the Jefferson Memorial
and it says I'm not an advocate of
frequent change of law and constitutions
but laws and institutions must go hand
in hand with the progress of human mind
as that becomes more developed we're
enlightened as new discoveries are many
new truths discovered manners and
opinions change and with the change of
circumstance in tissues institutions
must advance also to keep pace with the
times we might as well require a person
to we're still the coat that fit them as
a child as a civilized society to remain
ever under the regime of their barbarous
ancestors and the barbarous is a good
word because the brutality you know
against people in our past and still now
is unacceptable and yet this is a
hopeful quote and I think whether it's
religion or institutions or other things
you know we see this with the Catholic
Church with Pope Francis a modernization
and so you know another quote that's
important is at the National Archives
that says eternal vigilance is the price
of Liberty and so it's yet again our
turn but we're making some progress
towards that arc of justice towards that
future and again and my message is like
the more of us that get to play and the
more of us that support the doers that
have that in all of us the faster we can
solve challenges and come together thank
you so we as the nation between a month
and the two months to get ready to for
koban and we we didn't do very well
apparently we did
as well as the Asian Nations
I wanted to ask John Hennessy if how
much of this is about leadership you've
been exploring leadership for a couple
of years now
formally it is definitely about
leadership John we've we've recently
done two sessions with the mayor of
Seoul South Korea and you noticed South
Korea did a pretty good job even even in
dampening down a second wave that that
came after they opened up and they it
was about leadership it was about saying
here though some of it was also some of
us in the u.s. might find a little
undemocratic like comedic you need to
tell us you're going out of your house
and where you're going before you leave
your house but there was a there was
clearly first of all not kidding
themselves about the seriousness of it
they had had encounters with swords so
they were prepared for it I think we
were very poorly led and we were led by
somebody said it's gonna disappear and
that was a real mistake this is not the
first pandemic 1918 Spanish flu 50
million people died 50 million people
right you were you were roughly five
times more likely to die of influenza
than you were to die as a soldier in in
the first world war we should have
learned from that and we should have
been better prepared and you know Bill
Gates laid this all out and then a TED
talk and we all ignored it this is a
fundamental problem in this country I
think it's the same it gets to the issue
of climate change that Michael talks
about with data we do not pay attention
to things until there are crises look at
race relations look where we are right
now it has to be a crisis that summons
us all to action but maybe this time we
can make it an action that will change
in a fundamental way can I weigh in
actually with a guy on go ahead Michael
yeah thanks so this is a quote from Carl
Sagan and his great book the demon
haunted world
1995 okay so this was decades ago I have
a foreboding of an America
my children's our grandchildren's time
when the United States is a service and
information economy when nearly all
manufacturing industries have slipped
away to other countries when awesome
technological powers are in the hands of
a very few and no one representing the
public interest can even grasp the
issues when the people have lost the
ability to set their own agendas or no
knowledgeably question those in
authority when clutching our crystals
and nervously consulting her horoscopes
our critical faculties in decline unable
to distinguish between what feels good
and what's true we slide almost without
noticing back into superstition and
darkness now Sagan feared the impact of
pseudoscience I don't think he
envisioned the sort of malicious anti
science that we've encountered where
powerful vested interests have literally
worked to undermine the public faith in
science and technology and to impact our
politics in a way that portrays certain
areas of science as a threat to the
public interest
so that's dystopia Carl Sagan foresaw
the possibility of that sort of dystopia
and of course it sounds remarkably like
what we're living through right now and
yet I want to read another quote of his
and it's from the novel and then made
into a movie contact which indeed is
about our you know making contact with
intelligent life elsewhere in the
universe and and so he also foresaw a
positive vision of the future and
there's a quote that I think is
wonderful and it's from sort of the
alien civilization communicating to the
astronaut played by Jodie Foster in the
film he's taking the form of her
deceased father saying you're capable of
such beautiful dreams and such horrible
nightmares and so he recognized the the
duality in the conflict within our
species when it comes to the choice
between dystopia and utopia and I just
thought those quotes were relevant
this conversation thank you I you know
after the election I became fascinated
with the 538 websites men appalled and
through all of this the last almost four
years it's it's been a real barometer of
how divided our society is and it's just
stuck through everything you know the
Donald Trump has his popularity is
hovered around 40%
- plus about three or four percent I was
startled by that initially and then I
thought that it was actually pretty
profound that it was it was evidence of
something that I don't completely
understand and I was wondering if I
could get one of you to step up to the
question of the division in this society
where does it fit with respect to
leadership or is that about social media
what are the factors that have have made
that such a frozen number common first
just to make the comment because I I
think it relates when people were
talking about dystopia we're a funny
panel because we're not really very well
hahaha we're not very representative of
the America or the world population and
we think it's dystopian but I know there
are I don't know well let's say 40
percent of Americans who don't believe
it's dystopian and I think the figure is
even higher than that you know there's a
you requires a certain amount of leisure
time and thinking a lot to get so upset
and and so that to the point where this
thinking that it's all dystopian is what
dominates your thinking that's
definitely a minority view out there in
the world or let me add to that if it is
dystopian they feel it's dystopian for
another reason they can't get a job they
can't put food on their tape on the
table they're you know
baby died when he or she was eight
months old so I think that we've got
this divide that on the one hand you
have this sort of intellectual class of
which Silicon Valley belongs to and on
the other hand you have a lot of other
people who are just trying to live life
and don't really care a lot about
politics and they can they can get taken
advantage of cynically or not by people
who see politics as a game that they can
win if they manage their photo ops
carefully enough I'll stop there yeah
let me on I think there's a new book out
called death of despair by two Princeton
economists that really at least for one
subset of the American population does a
really good job of analyzing the forces
at play and why they've led to such
great divisions and the big division is
the one that Carmen alluded to
college-educated versus not
college-educated and it's become a
determinant of so many outcomes in life
now on top of that we then build systems
which accentuate the divide there's good
evidence demonstrated evidence down that
the primary system basically picks
candidates they're more extreme than
candidates that are represented the
middle of American thought about things
so I think we have to look both at our
systems but we also have to look at
education and and how we can brought
better education just a question for
John yeah this is what I can't
understand how do we explained it that
well educated quite well-off Trump
supporters I mean you know people who
it's not they're not necessarily stuck
in the Fox Breitbart you know universe
of thought and knowledge they know yeah
I think there are a small number of
people some it's economics although most
people I know
have not opted most people with wealth
not hot to vote for Trump but there are
some there are some libertarians a Milla
ya Bible very fundamental Christians who
care about who he puts on the Supreme
Court that's there and they will vote
that no matter what so I think we have
this small group but we have a larger
group of Americans who has Carmen said
they're disaffected and he that's that's
the group the Trump helped by the
electoral college structure animated
Paula and Carmen in micro time where
everybody is tempted to treat the
symptoms and not the cause you know it's
what's going on today stating the
obvious or reminding us the obvious
we're in this middle of this shift from
mass media to personal media and that
personal media shift whenever we have a
new media shift people go crazy for a
generation or so and then things begin
to sort out we've been through it before
but this is a moment in time in which
digital media quite literally is the
solvent leeching the glue out of our
global institutions and the shift the
personal media has caused everybody to
overemphasize on the personal voice and
it's working against the most
fundamental thing we need to create a
new global civilization and it's a very
old idea that the the essence to the
success of a society lies in social
cohesion was first articulated by even
khaldoun in the 14th century in the
macadam a-- where he pointed out in his
study of history of the north african
tribes that smaller cultural units and
and city units prevailed over larger
ones when they had higher social
cohesion the problem today is that
digital technology has done more to
destroy collective social cohesion than
anything else and it's been going on for
for for decades now that's what we have
to fight against it isn't about
creating new institutions or any other
stuff it is you've got to go to the core
issue how do we recreate social cohesion
when our technology that we invented is
pulling us all apart carbon next and
then Mike I think oh and then I'm sorry
kill and kill wants to talk to them Mike
and then carbon
I just wanted to admit that I'm sitting
just outside of Washington DC I'm
distracted by the fact that a third huge
metal fence is being erected all around
the White House and the old executive
office building today and so this puts
me in the mind of you know the
everything that people have just said
about what's contributing to these
divisions and what Paul just said about
the massive media shift on top of that
we have to think about how this
different information environment is
being exploited by other actors and we
know that you know this digitization of
everything has enabled actors to attack
basic democratic systems and I just like
to say that the very inviting and
positive inclusive vision that Megan has
helped us see as possible is threatened
by what's happening right now and there
is a unmistakable foreign adversarial
thread that runs through this and I'll
just cite a couple books that have
helped me one I've finished the road to
unfreedom by Timothy Snyder which looks
at half of Russia use such tactics and
how fascism works which is about us
versus them and how making our society
or building on the divisions in our
society is how fascism literally works
and so we don't want to beat lumen doom
but we do need to have sexual
situational awareness about this
division in our society as a very
serious vulnerability
right next to the department yeah well
sort of touching on the same themes here
and it gets back once again to sort of
the the the foreboding that that that
Sagan had for a world in which you know
ignorant is exploited by bad actors who
prey upon xenophobia and chauvinism and
bigotry and intolerance and we're seeing
that play out today
we're seeing you know as Carol just
alluded to bad state actors exploiting
that in working together with the
current administration to exploit that
that bigotry and chauvinism and nativism
to divide the the electorate and you
know for understanding that that is
their path to reelection and continued
powers is a divided electorate rather
than a United electorate and in preying
upon you know all of our intrinsic
weaknesses and you know Sagan I think
like you know myself he was a person of
Jewish ancestry and I'm sure he felt the
the legacy of the 1930s and Nazi Germany
and I'll just cite a number this is just
from the other day
the latest Reuters poll finds 37 percent
now let me get a 30 39 % job approval
for Donald Trump and 57 percent job
disapproval in the 1932 German election
Hitler got 37 percent of the vote I mean
his opponent got 55 percent of the vote
and I find the parallels between those
numbers quite disturbing because it
seems to speak to a universality when it
comes to sort of a subset of our you
know of our civilization of our people
who are vulnerable to the forces looking
to divide us along issues of race and
Jen
and I think we have to keep that in mind
Carmen you're muted but did you want to
add something I actually was not had not
raised my hand but but at this point now
I will say building on Michaels comments
in particular that I definitely consider
the possibility of the u.s. breaking up
into different countries as a result of
the dynamic that were on right now that
I mean I you know I think that and I'm
not trying to be partisan here but I
think that if Trump believes that he's
likely to lose the election he'll switch
his energies his tactics to discrediting
the election process and I think if that
happens there will be States I think
that will start the process where states
will think about seceding because if you
because States control the election the
state is an election is a state
responsibility and each state has its
own Electoral College which convenes so
I like to see something very ugly well I
don't know if it's ugly it may in fact
be the chaos that we need to reach a
better place so you know I just want to
point out that Gavin Newsom has been
referring to our state California as a
nation state recently and I don't think
that's by accident again or again in
Washington unite with Canada maybe some
of the you know the East Coast and just
leave the red states in the middle of
the Confederacy ecotone fear once bigan
this is gonna say it was this on the
Kofi Annan Commission around a democracy
an election and tack and that word and
you know the the challenges that we have
of the media bias and the propaganda
that can come through as as Paul's
talking like personalized media so some
people are hearing one thing some people
are hearing others a huge challenge it's
in every country you know Cambridge
analytic is a
business of course but it's still alive
with us in terms of the techniques and
the taking of data and running
personalised propaganda and so it's hard
for people because people have very
valid grievances around bias around
economic conclusion about the future and
so some demagogue can come through with
a message that sounds you know it sounds
okay but it's not and you're not hearing
the whole story very urgent
I mean it's very interesting to me that
you know in the current situation
project Alamo was the name of the
technology and tools I put a link
there's a BBC report explaining it forty
to sixty thousand Facebook oh that's a
day that was done for 2016 is now called
Death Star by brad pascal a who built it
who runs the Trump campaign and it's not
about one party it's about using these
technologies good or bad and really to
to get at people when they can't hear
other things so I combined that and sort
of harken back to John Hennessy your
point about education and access and the
sooner we can have people at all ages
building their confidence building
inclusion I noticed Nancy Blackmon and
David Desjardin are on the call you know
Nancy has been a pioneer about better
ways to teach math this is just a
language and we know that if you teach
calculus the Mexico teams did it's a
wonderful research say if you teach
calculus in kindergarten as a language
it's learned better than waiting for
high school so including mathematics and
it's not a contest thing you gotta
achieve but as something joyous that you
do with mentors that's not a big race
and stop making it about only certain
topics there are only interested certain
people like it's about anything there's
this wonderful thing that came out of a
bunch of colleagues d2 Institute DQ like
digital quotient like TQ Tech quotient
IQ you keep those things let's we can
drop IQ um but this idea of everybody
having digital skills you know an
English class you would learn to edit
Wikipedia and scripting and everyone who
know to code like stop biasing it so
that's like these flip sides of the
education point that John remake is
really about knowing
what's happening to you in feeling more
power about these tools and inclusion in
general as I've been speaking in general
but specifically around elections so
that this these death star like
technologies can't be use against us a
good Islam little Americans just a
little bit I mean Paul's point about
social corrosion societal corrosion and
social media I wanted to push people a
little bit about how to harness social
media how do we harness Facebook at
Facebook and there's some evidence that
that's true do you do it through laws
and regulations do we do it by modifying
section 230 or do we innovate our way
out of this is there anything on the
horizon that will replace Facebook and
not be as corrosive and divisive anybody
well I think Facebook speaking and
Facebook is the logical end of the last
chapter of social media that began with
MySpace and others I think the right
place to begin is there's this very
dangerous idea in Silicon Valley that
technology is neutral and John you've
written about this and so I know you're
the first one to disagree that our
technological artifacts are our
congealed culture and their concealed
values and assumptions and Facebook is
just the perfect congealing of the
founders weird ideas and if we start at
that level then say how do we create new
platforms that reflect other cultural
values is the way to go
Facebook I think is gonna collapse under
its own weight
I'm not too terribly concerned about
that and I'm more concerned about can we
build the new things the right way
that's occurred with social media and
creating these so-called walled gardens
and echo chambers I don't see an easy
way to make that go away unless you
somehow induce people to create
some sort of public square where there's
some mixing we've lost this we lost the
town wall people go into their Facebook
echo chamber and they hear opinions that
confirm their own biases I think this is
a really hard problem one which I have
to admit that we in the valley didn't
see coming we really didn't see it
coming carpenter quell do you want talk
it all about social media outside of the
United States you know we're only part
of this equation I don't think I have
any particular knowledge or insight
about how how it's different so I would
prefer not to comment funny Carmon do
you have any thoughts no I I don't have
any thoughts other than to note the
obvious that some countries notably
China have a very different policy here
philosophy about social media and how to
how to control it and I was also I don't
know how many anybody else has read the
book the history of the future in 100
objects was written by a guy who runs a
gaming company but also had a
neuroscience degree anyway
I was always intrigued by his idea that
at some point in the future a new
religion would emerge a religion kind of
a philosophy of how to live around an
app that people would compete to score
points in and that there would be some
ulterior purpose behind it but that you
essentially the app would tell you and
reward you for how you lead your life
and that is certainly something that
China is doing right now that sounds
very black bearish John and it's
interesting you mentioned black mirror
because the the producer creator of that
used to make more documentary and he
actually decided to go more into sort of
a fiction space to capture more people's
imagination and reach out on things that
he was very concerned about so it's
interesting the use of of media
just a year last point on the Commission
the cookie non-commissioned we did spend
time with various groups and I would
note that the team in Mexico that
selection was 2017 so they had the
bricks and other things that happened so
they they noticed ways that they as a
commission to could quickly share
knowledge and there were some great
practices that came out of that second
thing that happened is the electorate
electorate the citizens themselves were
more conscious of the gaming of the
system so the combination of sooo I
would say you know very similar to the
leadership in Minnesota who noted that
those who are the majority of the people
on our streets are very peaceful
protesters and there's a set of people
who are creating violence and rioting
burning build as those things and that
and that well some of those people may
be extremists some of them are also
infiltrating on purpose to do that to to
be hurtful so the more conscious we all
are of what's going on around us even if
it's complex
I would note you know at the beginning
of the call I had to join by phone
because it's the only moment we could
get the cap and gown for the
drive-through graduation of my high
school senior this year he's born we
noted of the class of 2020 they were all
born the high school class are all born
right as 9/11 happened there's no world
that's not complicated that they've
lived in and that's I think why gen Z
gens me you know John you have them on
your campus at Stanford and all of us
have them already there's so
understanding complexities and still
able to move like the Parkland kids and
I'm excited about them and and the
college kids who were entering
kindergarten on 9/11 times and are now
graduating this year I'm excited for
these colleagues joining us what they're
doing on the streets people like
Brittany PAC at the group that's doing
the 21st century policing work that
President Obama regional ed that
coalition of collective genius you know
asking our leadership to sign up to you
know all the things that are the best
practices that are around in a few
places that could be ever these kinds of
moves collective genius better sharing
using the internet through the utopian
goals that it was founded on faster and
sooner and
whistle blowing on when it's not so that
more people have consciousness and are
respecting respected for their ability
to do something about it when they see
it and including the last thing it says
if Facebook had more gender balance race
balance geo balance topic balance we
would have less of a problem with their
products I think if Mark would allow it
I think that's one of the central things
I'm sure there were many engineers in
those rooms especially diverse engineers
trying to get rid of bullying trying to
get rid of fakeness trying their hardest
and their priorities were dismissed for
shipping the product which is one of the
central challenges in suckin Valley is
sometimes we talk about X you know all
these X it's really X Y like how QP
broaden this out and include the rest of
the world like and these master tools or
just even move to another space where
more funding could go to others as well
it's an and the challenge that we're
supposed to be addressing here in the
next three decades I'm very curious
about the consequences of the pandemic
there might be macro and I was wondering
in particular you know the world has
been globally gambler gathering in
cities increasingly even despite these
science fiction notions about
suburbanization and we've actually been
urbanizing there's anybody in this group
believed that the pandemic is enough of
a forcing function to reverse that Paul
first and then Carmen so it what it's
going to do is increase the diversity of
choices we're not going to flee cities
the great irony of the current situation
is that everybody's figured out that
living downtown isn't fun during a
pandemic because all the restaurants are
closed and the super rich paranoid have
discovered that their former Titan
missile bolt holes are about fun for
maybe 15 minutes and they miss their
mansions the charismatic exurbs are
discovering that like Aspen that they
are kovat hot spots and so the great
irony is that the safest place to be in
this pandemic
is in the one place everybody wanted to
get out of the suburbs you know at the
boring rancher suburban house in
Cupertino
with a bit of a yard and close access is
complaining as a forecaster I deal with
indicators and an interesting an
indicator is what's happening in Carmel
last week that there is a real estate
boom in Carmel California because a
whole bunch of people have realized
thanks to zoom they can live full-time
in a nice little place like Carmel and
all the wealthy Texans have decided that
instead of timeshares they would be
better off with their own house
so I think what this does is it it
doesn't reverse the trend towards
urbanization you know 2009 was the year
that the first time in human history our
human population became majority urban
New York thought it had a happen 200
years earlier but it really only
happened in 2009 that's not going to
reverse in part because as Stewart Brand
is so brilliantly written it's the place
of Economic Opportunity but what we're
going to see is a species radiation of
lots of different options of people
exploiting the opportunity to deliver in
different places yeah I think probably
have to look distinguish between the
developed world in the emerging market
countries whatever you want to call them
I mean we have the luxury of saying okay
I'd rather live where Paul lives in the
suburbs and live in the middle of New
York City or whatever but I think that
you know before the pandemic certainly
the predictions were the forecast I
would say was we're gonna add between
two and three billion people to cities
by 2050 maybe two billion people to the
global population that is will be 70%
maybe kerbin of nearly 10 billion people
and I don't know that that trend is
gonna change especially in Africa and
Asia and other places where it's really
not a lot of options I mean people don't
go to cities because they're they could
now move from the
herbs into the nice high-rise apartment
they're trying to survive and they're
looking for jobs and they're moving off
of it the rural economy so I don't know
the deck that the option is there to
change but certainly they're very aware
and favelas and slums around the world
the the fact that they cannot do social
distancing they can't get clean water
and soap that they are much more
vulnerable to the pandemic than those of
us who live in nice single houses or
apartments where we can just you know
wall ourselves off from everybody so
this is really a problem I think that
all these cities whether it's Lego
swords
you know Santiago or Dhaka whatever are
gonna have to be figuring out what do we
do now with the fear of this pandemic
and future pandemics but we're gonna be
adding more people and and you know this
is we think of that it's a couple
Tokyo's a year of expansion of urban
centers I mean how do we do it do we get
you know Lagos or Karachi or Copenhagen
what are we gonna get so this is this
problem is gonna be with us big time of
the whole question of urbanization
throughout the world and then how do you
you know urban is where people live so
that's where we have to especially deal
with climate change right how do we
green these cities how do we how do we
move to transportation systems that
aren't just more fossil fuel cars which
everybody wants in the developing world
understandably so I think the
organization problem is is gonna be with
us but maybe there are more
opportunities to to bend the ears of
people to see alternative ways of
urbanizing alternative structures as Ban
ki-moon said that you know though the
war on climate changes we won or lost of
how we do urban and I think Michael on
Sherwood is would agree with me on that
one that you know this is this is the
opportunity and this is the danger if we
don't get it right in cities we've lost
the battle
so that battle is still going to be with
us and even though the rich people in
the developing world can think out you
know I'll move out to the burbs or go to
money Hamptons second home but that's
not an option for
more than a tiny percentage of the
world's population so let me ask an
artifact of that question let's say we
have a therapy or a vaccine best
possible case in a year and people
actually could go back to work they
could go to the supermarket safely how
much has this been a forcing function
we've so in love with zoom and so on
well with the Amazon that we will change
our our behaviour post pandemic Paul
first so as I said I'm a futurist with
the past and way back in the 1980s I
spent a lot of time doing one research
study after another about video
conferencing and groupware and trying to
explain to companies why it was a useful
tool I even wrote a paper for eighties
management titled believable broadband
for business now in retrospect after in
the last several months of endless zoo
meetings the my temptation is to throw
Molotov cocktail into the server farm of
Zune so we finally get some peace and
quiet I don't think we're it's it's not
is this substitute for something old
it's a world of this and the next thing
that what we've discovered through this
period is what real-time video
conferencing its strengths and
weaknesses and that is going to be
incorporated into business that it's
just the continuing pattern of unlocking
the tight coupling between what we do
for work and where we do the work and so
it's gonna receipt a bit back after this
is over but it's going to remain as an
essential business tool and also there's
going to be a whole new wave of startups
who say there are better ways to do this
whenever we have a new technology we
always use it to do an old thing in a
slightly different way a classic example
is plastic when william baekeland
invented bakelite thermoset resin
everybody spent their whole time trying
to make it look like
towards a shell and about ten years in
em they eventually realized and made
really tacky tortoiseshell and they let
plastic be plastic and things got
interesting well thanks to this pandemic
we're fast-forwarding in through the
bakelite phase of videoconferencing and
you know this is why I love the fact
that there are all these layoffs from
uber and airbnb and engineers are
disgusted with Zuckerberg and leaving
because remember zoom was started by a
refugee from WebEx and so in this chaos
we're throwing all sorts of
entrepreneurs out of companies and
they're sitting around with big ideas no
adult supervision and shoestring budgets
and so I am absolutely certain we're
going to see an explosion in new forms
of media startups in the next 12 to 24
months and we'll look back and laugh at
the idea that we ever did something as
stupid and old-fashioned as stare at
each other in real-time on computer
screens so maybe you've been at this in
terms of interface for a long time you
know virtual reality has been the
technology that's on its way to being
the next big thing for 30 years now I
want you know before I could I used to
walk down the streets in San Francisco
and think that people staring and then
comma their hand couldn't be the end of
user interface there had to be a next
thing and I've been thinking that for a
half a decade is there a next thing
after after the iPhone well there's
always the next thing John I think but I
came here I would prefer to work on
inventing that next thing rather than
trying to predict exactly what it is
because the predictions are often wrong
I mean I think there are ways we can do
really clever environments that create
something that is as good as being there
it's harder to do with large groups of
people than it is to do say one on one
we can we can do something one on one
that is completely immersive and works
as well I think I think we have changed
I think I think the zoom experience is
going to cause people I think the valley
the first thing you're gonna see is a
lot more work from home and it's gonna
be a change that it's not a hundred
percent but it's significant and you'll
see that play out lots of ways going
forward we also want to get you know
work from someplace in the middle of the
country right in the middle of the
country really needs some sort of tech
jobs to grow there because that's where
so much growth opportunity is and if we
could figure out how to do this using
using connection technologies we'd be
we'd be better off I mean are we general
magic days you know sort of funny the
movie is being more successful than the
company with
so but you know eventually I went
supernova with all the ideas that were
directionally correct um you know I
think I'm I'm at dawn you know like I'm
reminded of the movie Harold and Maude
with the smell machine like who knows
where we're going I'm hopeful that we
can be more expensive about who gets to
get fuels and funding and coaching from
many more places because I got there's
over the seven billion call it plus
colleagues we already have someone
already has these solutions and and only
a tiny fraction would be in sukkah
Valley they could be anywhere um so
Tesla I said think about the universe's
energy frequency and vibration so
quantum you know who knows what we'll
figure out and learn and certainly
Native American colleagues have held on
to knowledge --is that are relevant in
this conversation for how we might
interact gloria steinem one of her
coaching points is gather gather often
the world is linked not ranked and as we
work on more equality and inclusion I
think we have to keep those things in
mind and and so we
we are very social being humans are
social so we wanted to be together and
there are things we don't understand
probably about being together pheromones
and connection and and you know what
would it is about frequency vibration
and energy and us and others when we're
connected so we have to be very mindful
of that and respectful of the diversity
of those experiences and making sure
that many people have a voice in how
that is so we just don't create you know
one of the things we're doing with
artificial intelligence and joy buuel
I'm Winnie algorithmic justice league
wasn't able to join in the conversation
in the end but you know her point is
everyone has a face and so face
recognition is everybody's design
opportunity and right now face
recognition only works worst he calls it
the pale and they all dataset it was
very very well on some people like in
the 90 percent and it works in the 70s
percent I encourage everyone to watch
her AI ni a woman Sojourner Truth Reeve
envisioned under AI so this stuff is
really relevant were codifying sexism
and racism and systemic bias inter
algorithmic code when ADA invented the
idea but she's not in the room and women
of color certainly the most left out of
in terms of funding and coaching on what
they would build so that's why I thought
you know with Jonathan I think we don't
know we have to do it and my hope is
that we broaden out who gets supported
to bring it forward with us together and
I want to put three lines under what
Megan just said Megan is absolutely as
always spot-on
and we're in a really dangerous moment
here why again as someone who has
followed the remote work technology for
three decades
it absolutely terrifies me that the
lightbulb has gone on over the heads of
companies that this is a great way to
monitor their companies even more
closely and I remember the first time I
visited a call center in Mumbai and saw
what life was like there
for people in the cubicle farms the
problem is that companies are starting
to automate all the wrong things about
remote work and so working at home for a
minority of people might sound like an
idyllic existence but I think for the
majority way things are headed right now
for not careful it is that we're
creating it's not the electronic cottage
it's the electronic tiger cage in which
to trap minimum wage employees and
capture their every click and every
thought and that just scares the living
bejesus out of me I'm not gonna ask you
to answer this question directly because
predictions about the future are really
hard but I do want to you know the the
pages of the business sections of the
webs on the web and the newspapers have
been littered with discussions of use
you shaded versus v-shape recoveries
which is of course very optimistic in
the sims there will be a recovery but I
was wondering if some one sort of step
up to how we think about the economic
situation and and what looks like it's
on the horizon are they thoughts not the
stock market John the economic situation
situation I think it's it was a fast
down it's gonna be a slower up sort
about you with one side stretched out
further that's probably likely you just
can't rebuild some of these industries
that fast and and some things travel
entertainment they're gonna be impacted
for quite some time to come
oh I I am struck by the fact that we
seem to have multiple parallel worlds on
the planet so we've all noticed with
astonishment how the stock market seems
Melissa fully unaware that there's a
crisis and and they're they're solid
economic reasons behind it that you know
there's a off-guard saying on Moscow
that in Moscow every day is Monday or
every day is Friday and then the rest of
the Russia every day is Monday and it
feels like that
more and more the case even here in the
United States there are a lot of people
trapped in eternal Mondays and a lot of
people who are enjoying eternal Fridays
and because of personal media there
they're passing each other in the night
except when the folks stuck on Monday
happened to block the freeway and
interfere with the people who are living
in Friday but of course the people who
live in Friday will have personal
aircraft pretty soon anyway so the fact
is that it's not it does the the
interdependence is in the economy also
seemed to be coming looser and the
question is is that truly foundational
or you know is this just another case
that would be a chapter in the revised
edition of Charles McKay's late
Victorian classic extraordinary popular
delusions and the madness of crowds
Carol well one of the really critical
uncertainties about all this especially
as regards the economy is will a vaccine
or some effective and safe treatment be
developed when will that be and can it
be distributed in an equitable way and
according to the experts I've heard and
I know found she has changed this a
little bit lately
there's just no guarantee that this is
going to happen I mean fact she said 12
to 18 months and others say with more
freedom to speak that that would require
everything to be go perfectly so my main
point and I have just finished these
alternative scenarios out to 2023 based
on some interviews is that if this
crisis we're at the beginning perhaps of
this pandemic and there are some
positive things to note about it in
terms of compliance with the stay at
home thing edik that we couldn't have
imagined a few months ago but it's been
enormously disruptive for everyone and
the longer it goes on I think we are
looking at you know someone said perfect
storm earlier but we're going to see
more of a convergence of things that are
already in the pipeline like extreme
weather events
hurricanes droughts on top of an already
prostrate economy that's just you know
totally on its back so this and then if
there is a vaccine if it's not equitably
or people suspect it's not equitably
being distributed then there's just so
much turbulence that's still coming and
you know I want to emphasize the
positive but I also need to underscore
that uncertainty very good funny well I
think I'm just on the vaccine side I
mean my sister Laurie Garrett has said
that the very best cases is three years
but even if we get a vaccine within 12
to 18 months then there's the
manufacturing and getting it to seven
and a half billion people and we face
all sorts of obstacles with patents and
everything else but even if he did
manufacture it it probably needs to be
something that is a nasal spray or taken
orally or a little patch if it's
actually requires syringes and
refrigeration and more than one dose how
are you gonna get that to all these
people you're going to need armies of
people I don't mean military but armies
of people volunteers going to every
place in the planet this is it's almost
impossible to think that this we could
vaccinate the planet within three years
maybe but that's very much the best case
and the other piece is just that they're
you know the we're gonna get spikes I
mean we're already not clear what's
gonna happen with the Ozarks and the
south and all the people rushing out to
you know they're free they're free
they're gonna go out and a party and
have a good time
they're super spreaders out there and we
could have a big spike even in this
country in the near term but there's the
whole question of the you know going
into the developing world which is just
really starting to get hit especially in
Latin America and it will be Africa and
then coming back to the northern
hemisphere again so it is actually not
certain will ever get rid of Cove in
nineteen and may be around for very long
time and that's gonna have economic
impacts I'm pretty pessimistic about
this kind of v-shaped bird hopefully au
shaped like John said
recovery I think there's a lot of summer
so we say wishful thinking on Wall
Street and and I've been wrong before so
I'm probably wrong now but I think that
we could really have very serious you
know reserves of lockdown there's we
have 40 million people you know on
unemployment we have a demand-side
problem supply-side problem the
industries that Johnson I'm not sure
this is all gonna come roaring back the
way that Wall Street hopes it will some
big be shaped return it just on the eve
of the election to bring back Trump I
think that if you look at the IMF
forecasts which are you know some say in
one case they said it could be worse
than the Great Depression the CBO well
the forecasts are not very positive by
the economists and the people that are
not necessarily invested in Wall Street
I pretty concerned that this is gonna be
a little worse than a lot of people seem
to think we're coming up against the top
they are Megan did you want to say good
thing that I saw Jose in the chat
talking about perspectives from other
places and I just wanted to share that
when we run the United Nations solution
summit people from all over the world
bring bringing solutions forward and and
it's incredible to see what we already
have that's working or promising one of
them out of Wales was a a vaccine
cooling solution that was so genius and
uses the fact that water is heavier as
just before it freezes at four degrees
so you never know what we might do and I
just wanted to share this coin and this
is a little bit of a u.s. thing but it's
you know in the United States coins they
say Liberty but we found that the very
first penny and if this was by Franklin
and Jefferson and Washington was called
it said Liberty the parent of finance
and Industry so this idea that Science
and Technology and freedom can be
connected is from 1792 and again honor
and us archives vigilance eternal
vigilance is the price of Liberty and so
I think this using technology
for good with each other scouting for
all the doers being inclusive we went on
a 25 city tech job sir
in 2017 and 18 and fun genius Americans
already fixing things and Birmingham and
you know in Cleveland and Cheyenne and
everywhere and so lifting up the talent
is what I hope you know that's been my
message for your conversation but and
and and and understand the complexities
the things like this panel what can we
illuminate together can we use the
internet for that that's the direction
we could take if we want to go towards
the positive I think and we can go very
wrongly if we do Jenna yes I suggest
that you give Dennis a minute or two to
wrap up he could not have said anything
all day and I think he should we should
hear from him
thanks mark I appreciate it thanks
everyone for participating in Dennis why
don't you chime in with the future of 83
well III continues in a sort of random
way with talks on all sorts of subjects
this a covering a pretty broad base
today we still don't have an answer as
to whether we're gonna have world's come
to it in 2050 2030 years even if he but
it's in a fascinating discussion and I
want to thank all the panelists it's
been marvelous and we have plans for
another another one of these this to
look into other parts of the world and
there will be information out on that
you know something like a month and I
think we'll continue this this was
extremely fascinating and I want to
thank all of the panelists for their
their participation the the tape will be
up on YouTube so everyone will be able
to watch what they said if they want to
or people who missed it in ketchup and
thank you very much